effectivement la consultation à 20 € a
aggravé le déficit l'augmentation de ses
honoraires devait s'autofinancer par des
contreparties demandé au médecins dans
la réalité ça n'a pas du tout été le cas
Brigitte briffo Christophe Montel dans
son rapport annuel la Cour des comptes
pointe du doigt les honoraires des
médecins la hausse de leur tarifs creuse
le déficit de l'assurance maladie de
près de 700 millions d'euros au
personnes âgées ces augmentations des
honoraires toute profession confondu euh
représente quelques 690 millions d'euros
on espérait que en
contrepartie les moindre dépenses du à
l'usage plus fréquent des génériques
permettrait au moins en grande partie de
compenser cette dépense supplémentaire
en réalité la compensation n'est que de
1 pour 10 environ soit une économie de
seulement 70 millions d'euros mais pour
les médecin le prix de la consultation à
20 € est largement justifié ils
affirment faire des efforts et avoir
changé leur pratique médicales c'est
vrai que toutes ces réformes qui en ce
qui concerne le meilleur usage de la
visite et en ce qui concerne la les
prescriptions de en générique ou les les
remboursements sur le le médicament le
moins cher quand il s'agit de médicament
équivalent c'est des mesures
structurelles donc qui vont donner leur
produire leurs effets sur plusieurs
années c'est après plusieurs mois de
conflit l'an dernier que les médecins
ont finalement obtenu la revalorisation
de la consultation de 18 à 20 € c'était
une promesse électorale de Jacques
Chirac un accord conclu en juin 2002
entre l'assurance maladie et les
syndicats est salué à l'époque par le
ministre de la
Santé il nous reste naturellement à
œuvrer pour dépenser mieux et c'est je
crois le grand chantier qui est devant
nous et que je vais entreprendre dans ce
climat de dialogue social et de
confience plus d'un an après forcé de
constater que le sauvetage de la
sécurité sociale reste encore largement
en
chantier